the hell tonight is the night of course
for batman so what do you love about
this iconic franchise i i love batman
when i first moved to america we had a
vhs batman tape and i watched it
24 7 and i wanted to be catwoman i
wanted to be poison ivy i wanted to be
all the girls so she'll be all the girls
yeah so i'm excited to be here and
yeah well you were a girl that was
really having a moment because of a
high-profile relationship that you were
in it has since ended how are you doing
i mean it was the best thing that could
have happened to me why do you say that
it kind of
re it was like hitting a reset button it
kind of re-brought a spark into my life
that i had kind of forgotten about i
guess so are you back on the dating
scene um
i just i don't even have the time to
like brush my hair i can't i don't i'm
if i meet someone yes i'm not gonna you
know nature plays its course and someone
comes along i'd be more than happy to
entertain it but i'm not looking for
anything right you're still in touch
with kanye at all we're still friends
yes but it's nice to end on friendly
terms yeah always
yeah okay no inspiration behind this how
did you even get that on do i even want
to know um it took a while these are
actually these are actually pant pant
boots i know they're fantastic
my uh my stylist perry and brianna had
them made for me and we were kind of
channeling catwoman
thank you so much julia it's nice to
have fun